hi everyone we are here together Natalia
Zea by Ann kaczka and Bukowski we are
deep learning engineers in Linux polka
and our today talk is in the service of
the histories AI in our physics so let's
start our presentation is about one of
the lastest projects for public archive
in Poland so starting from the very
beginning first photo ever made was made
by Anisa for nibs in 1826 and it was the
photo you can see on the slide who it
was view from the window a telegraph
since then humanity produced 10
quadrillion photos 1 quadrillion only
last year and the amount of photo is
increasing by 10% each year so we have
many old photos and they are very
valuable because you know they describe
the cultures diet that we didn't
experience the situations that we didn't
so and we need them as a society to be
archived in a maybe in the internet that
we can see it but the amount of photos
is enormous now and will be soon even
bigger sometimes one volt a one month
old photo is old enough to be placed in
the public archives because as a society
we need every election every parade to
be well photographed we are quite sure
that every photo that is important for
us will be eventually placed in their
archive but then they are stacking in
the shelves the boxes and our social you
useless we can put them to the internet
just like that but they won't be able to
find we need the description we need a
tag we need a person who is on the
picture to be able to find a photo in
the Internet
our public archive has now 250 thousand
images described and published in the
internet and still 37 millions pictures
that are pending to be published you can
see the data set of the archive now it's
looking like this we have pictures from
the first and second world war interwar
period and a smaller peak for 70s and
80s and what is the current process flow
looking at the archive now now we have
photos in the Box in the boxes and they
are labelled together in assets from
occasion or place and their scans
together then we have a specialist who
will describe them so all the photos
from one occasion has the same tags the
same description then we have the
description you can see below and
eventually all the photos are show to
the committee of specialists though they
are historical huge educated people and
we need them more there to check if the
description is OK and this is how the
description looks like we have a title
the description date place people
visible on the photo and this invisible
for example it's a when it's a funeral
the invisible people will be dead dead
one tax other proper names for example
the name of street or theatre when
there's something the photo was made it
was made the workshop outer unit and
signature and for sure we know only
and unit they are always given other
things may be given but also maybe not
and the history can I need to invented
them here you can see some examples the
first photo is a hunting gear and the
tax given to the photo was hunting and
horses the second photo was in the beach
and the attacks was laser and the third
photo was his visit in France and the
tax was celebration and diplomacy so our
first aid solution that we made for the
specialist was to give them people
visible on the photos and automatic
tagging of the photos why this was quite
easy problems and we were sure that we
can handle it and only these two
problems give us about five minutes
saved for the photo so when we have 37
million photos you can see how much time
we can save now okay so let's first talk
about tagging if you want to assign some
labels folder for the image for example
here bridge and River it's a classical
problem of computer vision and deep
learning
it's multi-label classification so first
it's some few words about data on the
right you have word cloud a bigger word
more occurrences in our data set we have
about 10,000 images with without an
attack so we don't use them we also have
more than 200,000 images with at least
one tag all these images contain for 460
mm tags so it's about 2 tags per image
we have 6620 one unique tags and most of
the photos has have less than three tags
only 10,000 of them have five and more
tags this is the histogram of this tags
on the x-axis you have 50 most common
labels in our data set on the y-axis
it's the number of occurrences and what
you can see that the first tag
celebration it's on above to 20,000
images that then then is theater army
architecture sports Second World War and
so on
what's important that the data is
long-tailed okay so we took some
experiments our assumption are following
we took only 20 most common tags just
for expects just for experiments we said
50 epics
we used matrix as multi-label accuracy
and f1 score and we use baseline as
bigger lanit bigger because standard
Leonard is 28 by 2028 but our land is
224 by 224 and we split our dataset into
three parts train set which is 70% of
the original data set and validation set
15% and test set 15%
also what about multi-label accuracy the
standard accuracy is true positive + +
true negative
/ - positive + false positive + false
negative + true negative but who cares
about true negatives we don't so we get
rid of them and we call this our own
defined matrix multi-level accuracy
this is experiment this is the first
experiment our baseline Lynnette so we
can compare next experiments to this you
can see on the Left the chart of the
validation loss on the validations set
on the right multivariable accuracy on
validation set and on the bottom you
have results on test set so what we can
see here is our our model is over fitted
after 10 epochs multiplied by accuracy
it's not perfect and results on test set
are following Multi multi level accuracy
is 0.12
precision is 0.57 and recall zero point
eleven and f1 score 0.18 so it's not
good but okay of course it's our
baseline so we still have a lot of space
to improve next experiment we change the
net to state-of-the-art model and we
also over fitted this this network but
the results on test set are much better
because multi-label accuracy is 0.58 51
and for example f1 score is 0.61 but we
can do more so we add some augmentation
just simple augmentation like zoom like
horizontal flip width and height shift
shear and brightness you have some
examples on the right if you have image
like this this is original image
this is flipped image zoomed where the
traffic light is bigger and brighter
image were ever think is lighter and
here is example of shear augmentation so
after this augmentation we we we had
next experiment so this state-of-the-art
model plus augmentation so ok our model
is still over fitted from from this
point and what what Korea's that our
results are better I think it's it's
[Music]
some better ok because it still is very
space to improve but multi-label
accuracy is better by 10% and what F 1
score is better done 7% so it's it's
good but ok we can do more
do you know focal loss its its modified
cross entropolis so here you have cross
entropolis standard cross entropy loss
and if you add this coefficient to the
Crescent rupee loss 1 minus pity to the
power of gamma you have focal loss if
you set gamma to 0 you still have the
same cross entropy loss but if you set
gamma to something more than 0 you have
focal loss which don't care doesn't care
about well classified examples and the
crease is the loss of well classified by
examples still preserving loss for bad
classified examples so [ __ ] loss
although allowed to focus on difficult
examples okay so state-of-the-art model
plus vocalist without augmentation and
what about results multi level accuracy
is better by 3 percent in comparison to
state-of-the-art model and f1 score is
better by 1% but ok let's check another
thing if you want to maximize
multi-label accuracy we can add it to 2
loss so we create our own custom loss
which is crossing through P plus 1 over
x accuracy Y 1 over multi-level accuracy
because we want to maximize multi level
accuracy so at the same time we want to
minimize 1 over multi level accuracy and
next experiment state-of-the-art model
with custom loss no focal loss just
custom loss and what is what interesting
there is no overfitting and results are
better by 5% in multi level accuracy and
3% in f1 score so we
next we tried state-of-the-art model
plus augmentation and plus custom loss
and the same no overfitting so far and
multi-label accuracy better by 11% and
f1 score better by 7% okay here we have
comparison of this all of these
experiments the colors are the same so
last experiments is gray and the green
experiment was state of the art model
with custom Honda's custom loss and so
on so the question is why the loss is
bigger in in this case because our loss
is different so we have this additional
coefficient 1 over x curacy is that as
the reason dye why our loss is bigger in
these two examples what about
multi-label accuracy red and gray line
are the best and red and gray line was
with augmentation so okay but we have
comparison in table here is the
state-of-the-art model and next model
with augmentation focal loss custom loss
and custom loss and augmentation and
what we can see that multi-layer
accuracy 11 percent better precision is
a little lower by 4 percent and recall
is better by 16 percent f1 score 7
percent so we don't care about precision
if we have so much improvement in other
metrics ok but our experiment was on 20
tags but we want to of course assign
more tags so we then tried to to teach
our network to assign one of one or more
from 100 labels of course results are
worse because the problem is much
difficult because we have five times
more labels but ok it's it's after first
few few first experiments so we have
some ideas to improve it and we still
have what to improve okay
so let's see results this is the first
image and our our network assigned this
free tax churches panorama and temples I
think it's okay the second example
network size cities sites urban
architecture I agree
okay next picture meetings Association
than the religions I think it's correct
because his cup
he has cup with cross here so would be
religions okay and the next one
anniversaries and army okay I agree
maybe should be also your banana
architecture or cities like that
something like that but but but it's
okay but of course our neural network is
not perfect so we have some errors the
first one our model size funeral funeral
second world war army and government
okay I can agree that there is army and
probably there is second world war
because they uniforms or something like
that but there is no government or
funeral but if you remember
Natalia said that couple of pictures are
tucked together so maybe there is a more
pictures from this event and some of
them have funeral and government and was
target with this for tax so our net
Network mmm learn from other pictures
that these guys on this images this is
the specific event and there is sure
that this is funeral at government but
there is something more curious this is
from and maaske police polish politician
from interwar period but our model said
that is more automotive why automotive I
have no idea but maybe let's let's do
some CSI
oh yeah there is polymers in his eyes so
that's explain everything just kidding
of course we don't we have no idea why
there is automotive and we need still to
investigate it ok so let's talk about
face recognition it was our second case
only by now we have more than 37
thousand people in the data set and the
data set it's not a very big one so is
there any historian that would know all
the people I suppose no one so how much
historians how much special is doing it
to hire to be sure that we recognize all
the people as as many as we can I think
but if we will hire every historian in
Poland and told them to recognize the
people on the pictures will they
recognized everybody
no they they will not and the solution
is an AI of course we made a face
detection on old pictures then we change
the characteristic facial parameters
into vectors then we compare vectors to
each other and if the similarity exists
the accepted threshold we recognize the
people as well-known here you can see a
Hitler Ribbentrop and you can see the
word cloud of course the bigger word the
most the more occurrence so we can see
that it not the most risky is the most
photographed person in our in our
dataset the second person is Suki we
have more than 93 thousand images with
people there are about two people on the
sometimes there are more people in the
image we have even 11 images with more
than 30 attacked people here you can see
the histogram of the first 50 people as
you can see much TT has more than 2000
5500 images then it's decreasing very
fast and it stops with about 500 images
per person if firstly we decided to take
100 people because 100 is a nice number
but work we decided that there are many
interesting person that we should add
and now we have 125 people and we made
for them the references photo base we
found a photo of the faces and and made
the base for for every person it was
from 2 to sometimes 6 pictures about 4
per person more for actresses singers
because they are working on the stage
and you know they are looking sometimes
very different they are some they are
starting young and ending cold less for
politics because they are mostly adults
when they are in service and here we
have our result they were outstanding we
have 90% precision and the precision was
that small only because we recognized
people on the monuments and paintings
and we counted as an error I think it's
not a big error isn't it and we have
also 65 percent record and it is a
problem but not that big sometimes
people are standing back to the camera
they have blurred faces and no no one
will recognize them by the face we just
know that they are them and the F score
is 76 purses % so I think it's nice here
you can see an example we have done John
Powell's second a second and Stefano
machine scan the first picture and this
is an error of course but I think it's
it's nice we have a Roman Tomas key on
the monument when the monument is
faithful we can recognize the people
even on them we have some nice results
on the two of these pictures we found
people that specialists didn't even know
that they are here here you can see
Bishop Yusuf Alex govern inna our our
network found him even if nobody even
know that he's there and here we have a
minister ignites a burner he was also
found during the work but of course we
have some errors on the left pictures we
have Stefan Krinsky you can see his face
here Ned our AI didn't recognize him but
we can see why
maybe maybe specialists recognized him
by his uniform or a company but his face
is blurred and unable to recognize and
we have also very rare problem it
doesn't happen much for a fact it's it
is the only one example of the error
here we have a woman recognized as
Alexandra Pilsudski and we are quite
sure that it wasn't Alexandra paluska
but as I said it's a very rare problem
how can we use our solution more we can
recognize
people that we don't know we can mark
the face as a reference picture and then
find every picture with the person in
our dataset then maybe we can find who
it is and this time it's a use of back
our Minister of Foreign Affairs during
the interwar period okay so what about
improvement inference our tagging takes
about half second and our phrase
recognition is slower twice so it's
about one second and of course it's
measured on Titan RTX GPU but do you
know this device this is coral from
Google it's Isaac connected to your
computer via USB and you can use it to
infer an inference neural networks
because there is accelerator inside it
costs less than $100 and what about time
our experiments say that the time is
almost the same so we have 37 millions
of pending images and approximately 5
minutes per one description what equals
three hundred fifty two years of
continuous work but if one image
processing takes only two seconds it
gives us 150 times speed up so our
neural network can process all these
images in little more than two years
what about future okay so we know that
outer and unit is are given we prove
that tax and people visible are possible
and signature is artificial number
workshop is and people invisible is
rather and impossible to
to read from image but title description
date place and other proper names we can
help archivist in this because there are
a lot of networks that can produce title
and description and we can estimate for
example date on based on photo
techniques or people or clothes on image
and also we can recognize places and
classify other proper names so we can
even automate more things okay thank you
[Applause]
only three minutes for question maybe
one small question I thank that great
Taksim is very important work question
is you have pictures from like a hundred
years span so I believe a camera from
1860 and 1920 behaved very different so
maybe you try and split the data in by
dates or something like that and train
different models maybe that brings
better results okay but I think for
people is it's almost the same so the
photo from the 20s or 60s is almost the
same so we we believe that the there is
no problem for neural network ok
thank you for the talk as you consider
100 classes but on very one of the first
I'd said that you have half-million of
classes yeah 600 okay so let let it be
600 something mm-hmm so are you planning
to actually build a classifier to
distinguish all of the classes it's six
to one yeah thanks yeah we have some
plans but this is what was beginning so
this is this was experiments on 20 tax
Denton 100 text and then we have planned
to to cover all 621 unique tax yes thank
you very much
[Applause]